je vais regarder la danse rayon
feuilleter chercher parcourir les rayons
pour catherine boucher dénicher un livre
dans une librairie est plus qu'une
habitude c'est un rituel
cette guyancourt toise achète entre 3 et
15 ouvrages par mois ça représente un
endroit où je peux trouver les livres
que j'aime des livres que découvrent des
livres que je peux faire découvrir aux
autres
ce soit ma famille mes amis mais c'est
important parce que ses livres je
pouvais y toucher je suis vos contacts
ils sont présentés c'est beau c'est
calme professeur de lettres dans un
collège fuyant courtois passionné de
théâtre et de poésie
catherine boucher a toujours aimé lire
jusqu'à ses 14 ans et environ un ouvrage
par jour avec une préférence pour le
roman elle ne s'interdit aucun genre et
rentre dans sa bulle vit toujours avant
de dormir quelle que soit l'heure à
laquelle je me coucher je lui dis
toujours entendre et ensuite je lis dans
la journée dès que je peux dès que j'ai
un petit peu de temps ça me détend c'est
c'est plaisir de retrouver les livres
que j'aime je ça me permet de préparer
tous mes cours que ce soit les cours ont
posé au collège que ce soit le théâtre
ça me permet de
de retrouver des connaissances des
émotions que je sais que je vais avoir
en reprenant tel livre catherine boucher
a transmis sa passion à ses proches tout
en respectant leur goût et leur rythme
les grands lecteurs comme catherine sont
principalement des femmes et les plus de
65 ans sont les plus représentés